I'm going to paint the very breathing  Pablo give me your hand  why I am a fortune-teller let's see it  billowing childhood well I have a very  good function and love will play a  current role in your heart an artist  must always see below the surface find  the ugliness beneath the beauty you must  come and visit me sometime see some of  my work  pretending to show interest in his  girl's earth because the bloom is of one  muse and you have decided to block  another my work is too safe I need to be  more offensive and in my work to shock  even if I bet the perfect painting no  one will ever look at it and see what I  see no one will know my name  [Applause]  brush my weapon  give me a museum  one of us is leaving nobody know we are  all given the most horrible violence  which is why my suffice so hard against  it  [Music]